yeah jay have toeing the slab and the
boogie down here today and you see on
the season this will be his fourth start
had one rough one where all the walks
came i think he had six in one start but
his last one against the red sox was
pretty good just one run given up
he might have an extra little extra life
on his fastball today and that's
what we're looking for early swing and a
miss
nimmo down on strikes one away
ground it to le meu he makes the play
and fires the first two away nice play
to the glove side by
lemay we talked about how he improves
the not only the offensive side of
the yankee lineup but this side as well
and in the first inning for jay happ who
hasn't pitched in almost two weeks
that's a nice play so here's luke boyd
he has been
a rock for the yankees with all the
injuries he's continued to produce
and now when he rips to right field
conforto turns
looks sia a bullet home run
into the short porch and right and the
yankees lead one nothing
boyd continues to do it well don't blink
when luke voigt
comes up to bat he is always ready for
that first pitch and he likes what he
sees here
they need jhap to pitch very well and
give their bullpen a little bit of a
blow
alonzo to count on strikes
swinging a tip into the glove of kratz
and hamilton down on strikes
runner goes cratch from his knees fires
got him oh what a throw from his knees
eric kratz
gets rosario trying to steal
that's out of the tony pena songbook
the tag is applied and the inning is
over
here's dj lemayo and it's so important
to get this guy back and david you could
you can make the argument that dj lemay
is the yankees mvp that's how good he's
been
in the year plus that he's been in
pinstripes like you know one day
i'm good that one has driven to right
field
conforto back makes the leap can't make
the play and the ball carrums into right
field
lemayo ground second now he's going to
third here's the throw from hamilton
and lemayo is in there with a triple
i'll tell you why
conforto really hit that wall hard the
mets trainer is out there to look at him
oh it hurts to hear it so he's gonna
stay in the game
now trying to pin him there with one out
with the yankees up one nothing in the
fourth
and frazier groundswell trying to score
the throw by davis the tag
on tockman and he's out nicely handled
by davis
ramos got the tag down talkman running
on contact
out of the plate that's it deep to right
center field that goes hamilton he takes
a look and it's off the fence
frazier around third he's going to try
and score the relay throw to the plate
they may get him rubbles with a tag and
he's out
two runners thrown out at the plate in
the same inning and it keeps the yankees
off the board
swing and a miss he strikes out smith
and that will do it j hath is still out
there he has pitched beautifully
77 pitches over six innings it'll be
davis conforto
and alonso against the yankee
left-hander
that one is ripped into left field and
deep going back as gardner reaches up
and he makes the play
brett gardner took an extra base hit
away from jd davis for the first out of
the seven
michael you don't know how hard this
play is for a lefty and left field to
reach across your body on a dead sprint
i'll tell you what in a one to nothing
game don't forget about this play
because it might have saved the game
right there hap
has been so good today this is just the
third time through the order here in the
seventh
no walks swing and a miss
conforto down on strikes brett brock not
with his best outing
working a second straight day he walked
three in that seventh inning leaving a
mess for jerry's familia to try and
clean up
again the 3-2 slider hits slowly
davis in love fires got himself retired
familia finds his way out of trouble in
the seventh picks up for brock
gets la mahi on a ground ball after
falling behind 3-0
take out half after seven in the third
innings three hits no runs no walks five
strikeouts 90 pitches and he's retired
the last
eight in a row and he gets lifted
ramos hooks one down the left field line
headed toward the pole
and stop off the points off the pole a
home run for ramos to tie
up the game ottavino comes in and ramos
greets him
with a home run off the foul pole to get
the mets even
second home run of the year for ramos
and it's 1-1 in the eighth
the yankees have runners on first and
third with one man out so the winning
run is 90 feet away
and they're ball close over the head of
ramos here comes frazier
and the yankees win 2-1 on a wild pitch
as kratts square to bunt but tantus
then threw the ball past his catcher and
frazier
scores the winning run and the yankees
break their seven-game losing streak
with a 2-1 victory over the mets